[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الى نشره الظهيره من
العربيه ساعه اخباريه مفصله وهذه هي ابرز
العناوين
بوتين يعتبر الهجمات على البناء التحتيه
الاوكرانيه ردا على استهداف اسطول البحر
الاسود ويحضر كليب من المزيد
محتاجون ايرانيون يواصلون حركهم ويهاجمون
مقرا للبسيج بمدينه اراك والنظام يلجا
للمحكمات العالميه
وسط اجراءات امنيه مشدده الناخبون
الاسرائيليون يبدون باصواتهم لاختيار
اعضاء الجنس
الامريكيه بزياده الانتاج وخفض الاسعار
ويتوعدها برفع الضرائب
اهلا بكم نبدا نشره الظهيره بالتطورات
الميدانيه في اوكرانيا حيث قال الجيش
الاوكرانيه ان الجيش الروسي ركز جهوده
لمنع القوات الاوكرانيه من القيام بعمليه
الهجوميه في محاوله الاحتفاظ بالمناطق
التي استولى عليها كما يواصلوا محاولات في
منطقه مدينه
الصواريخ المتعدده استهدفت عددا من المدن
والبلدات
الى ذلك اعلنا عمده العاصمه الاوكرانيه
كيف عوده امدادات المياه والكهرباء وذلك
بعد يومين من انقطاعها عن 80% من السكان
في كييف بسبب تعرض البنيه التحتيه لضربات
صاروخيه روسيه ياتي هذا فيما اعلنت
السلطات الاوكرانيه حاله التاهب جوي في
جميع انحاء البلاد تحسبا لغرات الروسيه
الجديده
وينضم الينا من العاصمه الاوكرانيه كييفا
زميل هاني سفيان لمتابعه تطورات لديه هاني
الانباء تشير بشكل واضح الى تكثيف في
الغارات الى السدادات القصوى في اوكرانيا
وفي العاصمه كيف تحديدا ضعنا في الصوره
هاني
صحيح نعم واليوم ايضا هذا ما يتعلق كما
تحدثت في المنطقه الشرقيه من اوكرانيا او
كذلك وسط العاصمه الاوكرانيه كيف ولكن
ايضا هناك الضفه الشماليه وتحديدا الحدود
اوكرانيه مع بيلاروسيا ايضا تشكل خطا رغم
ان حتى الان لم يتغير بشكل ملحوظ الخطه
العسكريه والعمليات الهجوميه الا ان
اوكرانيا قالت بان هناك تكثيف لي وانتشار
من قبل القوات الروسيه على حدود بلا روسيا
وكذلك اوكرانيا وقالت ايضا اوكرانيا على
لساني متحدثها باسم المسلحه الاوكرانيه
الكساند شوبون الذي قال بان ما زالت بلا
روسيا تدعم القوات الروسيه من خلال
تجهيزها للطائرات بدون طيار وكذلك
استعداداتها الصاروخيه من خلال همم الخطه
المستقبليه لها اذا كانت هناك خطه عمليه
عسكريه سوف تنفذها من خلال استهداف
المناطق الشماليه رغم العمليات ايضا التي
قالت عنها المسلحه الاوكرانيه بشنغارات
جويه من قبل روسيا وكذلك الستينا صاروخا
التي اطلقته وكذلك ايضا الراجمات الصواريخ
الا ان ايضا في الجانب الاخر اوكرانيا
استطاعت من اسقاط اربعه مروحيات وكذلك
اسقاط طائرتين مسيرتين وكذلك اعتراض اكثر
من 45 صاروخا من نوع كروز طبعا ايضا تحدثت
همم الاوكرانيا انها همم ان روسيا الان
اصبحت تقوم بالتهجير القصر للمدنينا الذين
يقتلون في مدينه خرسون واصبحت ايضا تتخذ
منها الدين برو موقعا استراتيجيا وعسكريا
وتقوم بزرع الالغام خطه زرع الالغام ليست
كانت موجوده في البيانات السابقه من خلال
ما يتحدث به المتحدث الرسمي باسم المسلحه
الاوكرانيه الكساندرو ولكن هذا المره تحدث
اليوم بان هناك زراعه للغام وهذا يعني ان
الان تبدا روسيا في زراعه الالغام
وتامين خطوطها الدفاعيه لتبدا التقدم
هجوميا نحو المناطق الوسطى من اوكرانيا
تفضل طيب
ومن خلفك تبدو الصوره لحركه سيارات في وسط
انباء تشير الى حاله اهه ايضا في العاصمه
كياب خوفا من طبعا هذه صور ينقلها لنا
المنفذ العربيه هاني صفيان من قلب العاصمه
الاوكرانيه اكيد تبدو هاني حركه همم
طبيعيه وهناك حركه للسيارات ولكن هناك
حاله من الحضر الشديد في تصريحات
المسؤولين الاوكرانيين في تتعلق بتوقع او
حاله من التاهب ربما لردود همم هجمات
روسيه
نعم حاله التاهب هنا في وسط العاصمه كيف
وهذه الصور التي ننقلها الان من وسط كييف
العاصمه الاوكرانيه صافرات الانذار هي كل
ساعتين الى ثلاث ساعات تطلق هنا في
العاصمه الاوكرانيه همم الصواريخ كروز هي
التي تصل هنا الى العاصمه الاوكرانيه هناك
قلق من المواطنين هنا في اوكرانيا رغم
ايضا همم محاوله جريان او جريان همم عملهم
اليومي وكذلك ذهابهم للعمل اليومي الا ان
الخوف من خلال سؤالنا لهم ما زال قلقا
ويشكل ايضا هاجسا همم نشاهد ايضا في
الاركان بعض الطرق وزوايا بعض الطرق
التحسبات والاجراءات الامنيه والعسكريه
التي اتخذتها الحكومه الاوكرانيه من خلال
وضع بعض الخرسانات وكذلك ايضا همم شابك
الحديد وهي مشابك عسكريه حتى تقوم باي كي
اجراءات احترازيه لاي امر عسكري قد يطرق
على العاصمه الاوكرانيه كيف وكذلك تحسبا
لاي اجراءات عسكريه قد تحدث مستقبلا اشكرك
هاني على هذه الصور الخاصه لنا من قلب
العاصمه الاوكرانيه كييف نقل هاني صبيان
حاله التاهب حاله ربما الاستعدادات
الامنيه والكتل الخرسانيه التي ربما
شاهدناها في الصوره منذ قليل سنظل معك في
هذه المتابعه الحيه دوما زميلي هاني صفيان
وراس العربيه شكرا لك
ده رئيس الروسيه بلاد المربوطين اوكرانيا
الى ضمان سلامه السفن التي تعبر ممر تصدير
الحبوب متهما كيف بانها تشكل تهديدا بعد
هجوم استهزاء ابعده هجومين استهدف الاسطول
الروسيه في القرنه وشدد بوتين على ان
روسيا لم تنسحب من الاتفاق بل علقت
التزامها به فقط وذكر رئيس روسي انها
جماعه امس على البنيه التحتيه الاوكرانيه
كانت في جزء منها ردا على الهجوم على
الاصول الروسيه في سته بول
من جانبه وفي حديث العربيه قال وزير
خارجيه الاوكراني ديميت ايكوليبا ان الطرق
البريه لا يمكن ان تغني عن الممرات الامنه
عبر البحر الاسود محذرا من مخاطر انسحاب
روسيا المنفرد من الاتفاق
[موسيقى]
هذه الطرق
بكل فاعليه لتلبيه احتياجات السوق
العالميه من الحبوب الاوكرانيه لكنه لا
يمكن ان تكون بديلا عن الطرق البحريه واذا
استمر روسيا في اهتزاز مبادره الحبوب فان
اسعار الغذاء في العالم سترتفع وسواجه
الملايين المجاعه في الطريقه الوحيده
لضمان صادرات الحبوب الاوكرانيه حول
العالم بشكل سلس هي من خلال الممرات
الامنه في البحر الاسود
وفيما يتعلق باتفاق الحبوب قال وزير
الدفاع التركيه خلصي اكار لنضجه الاوكراني
انه من الضروري الحفاظ على اتفاق تصدير
الحبوب بعيدا عن الصراع قبل ذلك حذر مندوب
تركيا الدائم لدى الامم المتحده من ان سفن
الحبوب التي تنتظر تفتيشها في مضيق
البوسفور افراع تعليق روسيا مشاركتها في
اتفاق تصدير الحبوب من اوكرانيا تشكل خطرا
ملاحيا
في السياق ذاته هي رفض المستشار الالمانيه
لاستخدام قنبله قادره وفي حديث هاتفيه
اجراهم مع رئيس الاوكرانيه اعتبره انا
عمليات التفتيش التي تجريها الوكاله
الدوليه
ستحضوا كل الشقوق على هذا الصعيد من جهه
اخرى اذان المستشار الالماني الهجمات
الروسيه المستمره على البنا تحتيه المدنيه
الاوكرانيه
قبل ذلك قال المدير العام للوكاله الدوليه
التي تقدريه رافاييل جروسي الى الوكاله
بدات عمليات التفتيش لموقعين نوويين في
اوكرانيا بناء على طلبكيات بعد الاتهامات
الروسيه بانها تعمل على صنع ما يسمى
بالقنبله القذره وقالت الوكاله في بيان ان
مفتش الوكاله بداوا وسينتهون تقريبا من
انشطه التحقق في موقعين في اوكرانيا ومن
المتوقع ان يقدم بروسي في وقت لاحقا هذا
الاسبوع
استنتاجاته الاوليه حول عمليه التفتيش
منذوبان الحرب في اوكرانيا لعبت الجسور
دورا مهما وحسما على ارض المعركه حيث تشكل
الجسور ساحه معركه قائمه بذاتها
شاهدنا هذه الصور للجسور التي تلعب دورا
محوريا في سياق هذه المعركه العسكريه
ونبقى معكم في نشره الظهيره من العربيه
ولدينا
بعد قمه سوشي ارمينيا وادربيجان تتعهدان
بعدم اللجوء للقوه لحل النزاع في اقليم
لاجورنو الكهربا
اهلا بكم من جديد
على عدم اللجوء الى القوه لحل نزاعما في
منطقه
وذلك في بيان المشترك بعد محادثات بواسطه
روسيه واتى هذا عقب قمه عقدت بمدينه سوتشي
الروسيه بعد شهر على مواجهه الحدوديه او
قاعه
286 قتيلا في اعلى حصيله منذ الحرب في
2020 لسيطره على منطقه
المتنازع عليها بين الجمهوريتين الصوفيتين
السابقتين
الملف الثاني في نشاط الظهيره لاحتجاجات
في ايران تتواصل هذه الاحتجاجات في مختلف
المناطق بايران واستمرت المظاهرات في
تبريزا عاصمه اذربيجان الشرقيه حتى ساعات
الاولى من فجر اليوم
مالك
وفي تطور جديد حتى طهران اعضاء مجلس الامن
الدوليه على عدم حضور اجتماع ان تنظمه
واشنطن بشان الاحتجاجات في ايران التي
اشعلتها عمليه مقتل الشابه مهسه امينه
وقال سفير ايران لدى الامم المتحده امير
سعيد عرفاني ان الولايات المتحده تفتقر
للمؤهلات السياسيه والاخلاقيه والقانونيه
المطلوبه لعقد مثل هذا الاجتماع ووصف
الاحتجاجات بانها قضيه داخليه ياتي ذلك
بعد دعوه مواجهتها الولايات المتحده
والبانيا لعقد اجتماع غير رسميه في مجلس
الامن في هذا الصباح
[موسيقى]
هذا وتواصل السلطات الايرانيه محاولتها
الحثيثه لاخماد الاحتجاجات المتواصله في
مختلف انحاء البلاد مستخدمتا كل الطرق
الممكنه لرضع المحتاجين اخر هذه الطرق
كانت اللجوء الى المحاكمات العلنيه
والاحكام القاسيه ضد المحتاجين
النظام الايراني يستمر بقمع الاحتجاجات
ويستخدم سلاح المحاكمه الاحتواء تظاهرات
التي عملت كافه ارجاء البلاد فبعد تهديد
المتكرر من قائد الحرس الثوري والرئيس بل
ومن خامنئي نفسه ماسكون بدوالي بالسلطه
يمرنا الى مرحله اخرى وتكتيك مختلف
والمتمثل بالمحاكمات بعد ما لم تجدي
التهديدات في كبح جماح الغضب الشعبي رئيس
دائره العدل في محافظه طهران اعلن اصدار
نحو لائحه التهام بحق متظاهرين اعتقلوا في
احتياجات العاصمه وحدها حتى الان لتتم
محاكمتهم بشكل عالمي هذا الاسبوع
بالاعدام في اول جلسه هل هذه عداله
اسلاميه في اي محكمه يصدرون حكما بالاعدام
في الجلسه الاولى انهم يريدون تنفيذ الحكم
باسرع ما يمكن رجاء ساعدونا
المحتجون رفعوا شعارات مطالبه بمحاكمه
رموز الفساد ليتم عكس ذلك عبر محاكمه
المحتجين من اجل كسر شوكه الاحتجاجات ولجم
السنه المتظاهرين اسلوب المحاكمه في حق
المطالبين بالحريه والعداله ورحيل النظام
ليست جديده في ايران اذ سلك الطهران طريق
نفسه خلال احتجاجات 2009
و2019 ايضا وفي الوقت الذي تعرف فيه
البلاد غليان شعبيا وارتفاع حصيله الضحايا
في صفوف المتظاهرين الى اكثر من 200 قتيلا
بينهم اطفال برصاص الامن وفق منظمات
حقوقيه ايرانيه صحف تابعه للحكومه
الايرانيه دافعت عن انشطه قوات الامن
وقالت انه لم يقتل اي محتج حتى الان مشيره
الى ان القتل جميعهم من قوه الامن عكس ما
تقوله صور الوارده بلال الوجداني العربيه
[تصفيق]
وينضم الينا من لندن الباحث في شان
الايرانيين السيد وجدان عبد الرحمن مرحبا
بك يا سيد وجدان الى نشره الظهيره من
العربيه هناك تحرك جديد على ما يبدو من
قبل واشنطن في فكره دعوه مجلس الامن موقف
من ممارسات النظام في ايران هل نحن بصدد
حركه دوليه مختلفه وخاصه من واشنطن هذه
المره
بكل تاكيد انه التحركات الامريكيه الان
اصبحت مختلفه تماما عن ما كانت عليه
سابقا وايضا اعلان اكثر من المسؤول
الامريكي وبما فيهم همم
تصريحه بانه الملف الايراني ملف المفاوضات
لم يعد على طاولات المناقشات في الوقت
الحاضر والتركيز فقط على موضوع الاحتجاجات
في ايران اضافه الى
فرض العقوبات على ايران الغيبه الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه وبعض الدول الغربيه
منها كندا وايضا دول الاتحاد الاوروبي
يشير بانه بالفعل تغيرت
الاستراتيجيه الامريكيه نحو التعامل مع
النظام الايراني
والتصريح بعض وسائل الاعلام الامريكيه
منها
همم الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
خرجت من الاتفاقيه النوويه وبدات بفرض
العقوبات بمعنى انه قالوا الايات المتحده
او اداره بايدين همم بدات العمل
[موسيقى]
بورقه القوه العسكريه في تصريح ربما تم
التركيز عليه بشكل كبير فيما يتعلق به
المحادثات النوويه اذا لم تلتزم ولكن نعود
الى مساله همم الاحتجاجات لانها مهمه
للغايه هل نتوقع ان تكون هناك بالفعل جلسه
لمجلس الامن الدوليه يتم فيها طرح هذه
الممارسات واتخاد موقف دولي مختلفه عما
حدث عام 2009
هذه المره سيكون الامر مختلف تماما في
2009 كانت اداره كانت اداره اوباما متواضع
مع النظام الايراني لان همم اوباما كان
همم
الحصول على الاتفاقيه النوويه مع النظام
الايراني ولذلك لم تخدم اداره اوباما على
اي تحريك ضد النظام الايراني لكنها اعتذار
اوباما وايضا همم الان بانه سيتابع موضوع
ملف حقوق الانسان هذا يشير بانه بالفعل
انه الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ستخدم على
هذه الخطوه هي همم خطوه نحو همم الطريق
الصحيح
الاخبار اليوم كانت هناك انباء عن ان
وزاره الخارجيه ايرانيه اعلنت عن عقوبات
سيتم فرضها على بعض الشركات والكيانات
الامريكيه تعلم ان نحن في الاخبار عاده
نشير الى العقوبات التي تفرض من امريكا
على ايران نحن امام مشهد مختلف الان هل
هذه العقوبه التي تتحدث عنها ايران هي
عقوبه حقيقيه مجديه ذات دلاله بالنسبه
لامريكا
اخبار همم تصبح محل سخريه واستهزاء
للمواطن الايراني قبل همم
اجنبي همم النظام الايراني هو بالاساس
بحاجه همم الى الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
وهو يعرف
المتحده لان بالاساس همم العقوبات اليوم
التي تؤثر على الاقتصاد الايراني العقوبات
الامريكيه على ايران فكيف الايراني عقوبات
على الدوله هو بحاجه بحاجه لها ولا يملك
قدره ايضا لتنفيذ هذه العقوبات ولا وجود
لهذه القدره او همم وجود هؤلاء الاشخاص
اللي يكون لديهم همم استثمارات او شركات
في الداخل الايراني لكي يتم برضع عقوبات
عليهم هذه محل سخريه فقط همم
الدعايه الاعلاميه لا غير نعم السيد وجدان
عبد الرحمن الباحث في الشان الايرانيه من
لندن تحياتي
هو ومن ملفات الظهيره يواصل الناخبون
الاسرائيليون التصويت في خامس انتخابات
الكنيسه خلال اقل من اربع سنوات وياخذوا
الانتخابات 40 حسبا وسط اجراءات امنيه
المشدده نشاهد في الصور هذه الصور لعمليه
الاقتراع التي تتم في اسرائيل وهناك
تقارير تشير الى ساعي رئيس الوزراء السابق
من يمينا نتنياهو للعوده الى السلطه في
هذه الانتخابات بينما يصعب الطبع رئيس
حكومه تصريف الاعمال
بها هذه الانتخابات جاءت بعد انهيار ما
يسمى بائتلاف التغيير الذي جمع ثمانيه
احزاب متباينه نجحت في الاطاحه بنت
ثانيهاه من رئاسه الوزراء ها هو نتنياهو
كما نشاهد هذه الصور المباشره يقوم
بالادلاء بصوته في هذه الانتخابات لتاكيد
هو يسعى للعوده من جديد الى السلطه بعد ان
حكما اطول فتره كرئيس للحكومه اسرائيل
هناك تساؤلات تتعلق بمعدلات التصويت بنجاح
اليمين المتشدد في العوده مره اخرى
بالنتنياهو الى السلطه من جديد في راس
الحكومه في اسرائيل
وايضا ما يتعلق بموقف الكتله العربيه والى
اي مدى يمكن ان تكون هذه الاتجاهات
للتصويت خارقه في النتائج ينضم الينا شبكه
مراسل العربيه من النظره مراسل العربيه
خالد القاسم ومن القسم راس العربيه زياد
حلبي مرحبا بكم الى هذه النشره نبدا من
زياد زياد كيف تبدو معدلات التصويت كنا
نتحدث صباحا معا في ما يتعلق به الفارق
بين هذه الانتخابات الاخرى هل نحن نتحدث
عن معادلات تصويت اقل اكثر كالمعتاد
لا هي مشابهه عمليا لا قيمه الان لنسب
التصويت لان الوقت ما يزال مبكرا سنرى في
ساعات الظهيره الارقام الرسميه وساعات
العصر والمساء هذه ما تحسن عاده المعركه
الانتخابيه بدون ان شك بان نسبه التصويت
هي اللاعب الابرز في هذه
المعركه الانتخابيه حسما بمعنى ان كان
هناك نسبه تصويت كبيره في الوسط اليهودي
ونسبه همم متراجعه متدنيه لدى العرب هذا
يعني بان ذلك سيعبد الطريق امام عوده
نتنياهو الى السلطه على راس حكومه تستند
الى ائتلاف من 61 نائبا كحد ادنى اما اذا
كان غير ذلك بمعنى صوت العرب بكثافه همم
عمليه في هذه الانتخابات هذا قد يحد من
قدره نتنياهو على العوده كما حدث بالضبط
في المره الماضيه فاما ان يشكل الكتله
الاخرى الحكومه المهم ان تذهب اسرائيل
اساسا الى انتخابات سادسه وهذا ايضا يبدو
ااه واردا رغم ان النجم الاساسي
للحكومه لهذه الانتخابات ليستانيه ولا
لبيد وانما المتطرق بين فير الذي سيحل
الحزب الصهيونيه الدينيه سيحل ثالثا على
الارجح وفي حكومات 61 مقعدا كل همم وزير
وكل نائب عمليا لديه نفس قوه رئيس الوزراء
تقريبا وبالتالي سيخضع نتنياهو او غيره
للاهتزاز السياسي طيب ابقى معي زياد سنذهب
الى زميلي خالد للاطلاع ايضا على النصره
يعني هناك توقع وترقب كما ذكر زياد منذ
قليل لتصويت الكتله العربيه في هذه
الانتخابات كيف تبدو المؤشرات لديك خالد
يعني حتى هذه الساعه في الوسط العربي كما
هي الصوره لدى زياد داخل اسرائيل نسبه
الاقبال على التصويت في ساعات الصباح
الباكر تكون ضعيفه بل ضعيفه جدا اولا لان
اليوم يعتبر يوم عطله في اسرائيل معظم همم
الناخبين يذهبون للتنزه عاده في يوم
الانتخابات وخاصه ان اليوم
خالد نجد صعوبه في سماع صوتك
تفضل نعم ولكن هناك كما ذكرت لك هناك
قلق لدى الاحزاب العربيه الثلاثه المشاركه
في هذه الانتخابات من ضعف الاقبال على
التصويت هذا العام بعض المحللين يازونا
ضعف الاقبال على التصويت لعده اسباب منها
تكرار الانتخابات والياس من تاثير اعضاء
الكنيسه الحرب
نعم ولا يبدو ان هذا اليوم سيشهد الحلقه
الاخيره من مسلسل الانتخابات الاسرائيليه
التي انطلق قبل ثلاثه سنوات اليوم
كان فارقا وبشده في الانتخابات الاخيره
جاء بتشكيل حكومه تبدو مختلفه عن كل
الحكومات في تاريخ اسرائيل الى اي مدى
نجحت الكتله العربيه
ونتحدثون عن الاحزاب في هذه المساله
القائمه المشتركه مثلا هل نجحت في حث همم
العرب على الذهاب لتصويت للخروج بصفقه
سياسيه شبيهه بالحكومه السابقه ام ان
المشهد الخاص بالحكومه السابقه لن يتكرر
وفقا لمؤشرات الموجوده على الارض
نعم القائمه المشتركه التي خاضت
الانتخابات الاخيره وحصدت 15 مقعدا لم تعد
قائمه اليوم تدخل تدخل العرب بثلاث قوائم
على امل ان يجتازوا نسبه الحزم ويحصل كل
تحصل كل قائمه على الاقل على اربعه مقاعد
كي يكون لهم تاثير في تشكيل الحكومه
القادمه اذا اما اذا حصلوا على اقل من
ثمانيه مقاعد فهذا بحسب همم الخبراء
والمختصين بشان الاسرائيلي هذا يصب في
صالح اليمين وتحديدا في صالح بنيامين
نتنياهو التي الذي سيتمكن من تشكيل
الحكومه دون الحاجه او دون تاثير لاصوات
العربيه في الكنيسه الاسرائيليه
التي ربما نشد الساعات الاولى منها اعود
الى زياد مره اخرى زياد كنت تشير الى نقطه
مهمه وهو ان هناك نجم جديد من الناحيه
السياسيه في هذه الانتخابات
نحن سنكون امام صراع سياسي همم وتنافسي
بين يمين المتشدد ويمين اكثر تشددا
هذا صحيح جدا همم ما سيحسن ماده
الانتخابات عملينا عمليا هما ضدان تماما
اما همم حزب المتطرف بين كبير اي اقصى
اليمين واما الاحزاب العربيه همم احدهما
عمليا سيحسم هذه الانتخابات لصالح احدى
كتلتين ايا كان في مخصص سؤال نعم همم
عمليه همم بين كبير بقى ظاهره في اسرائيل
عندما نتحدث عن شخص همم ادينا بانتماء
لتنظيم ارهابي في اسرائيل
وعمليا الحزب الذي يراسه الان هو اسمه
مطربرج من المتوقع ان يحصد حوالي 15 نائب
هذا يعزز ما كنا نقوله في السنوات الماضيه
بان التشدد اليمين او التطرف اليمين في
اسرائيل اصبح طياره مركزيا
وكما شرحت في حكومات ال 61 مقعدا هذه قوه
هائله بمعنى هذا ليس امرا عاديا يستطيعون
ان يغيروا نظام القضاء كما اعلنوا يريدون
ايه الغاء التهم ضد نتنياهو ومودريتش
يتحدث عن احلال حكم التوراه في اسرائيل
بدلا من القوانين العلمانيه وما الى ذلك
بهذا المعنى يمكن ان تتغير اسرائيل بنظري
السكانها اليهود على الاقل نعم شكرا لك
زميلي زياد حلبي والشكر موصول ايضا لزميله
خالد القاسم هذه قراءه لما يدور في الداخل
الاسرائيلي بتوقعاته المختلفه لتجاهات
التصويت نقلنا لحضراتكم هذا الجزء من
الصوره في هذه الانتخابات او في هذا
المشهد الحاصل للانتخابات في اسرائيل
لقى معكم في سياق نشره الظهيره من العربيه
ولدينا
بعد حله مجلس الاداره ماسكي يعلن نفسه
رئيسا تنفيذيه لتويتر ويؤكد التزاماتها
بسلامه العلامه التجاريه
الاوكرانيه ردا على استهداف اسطول البحر
الاسود ويحذر من المزيد
محتاجين ايرانيون يواصلون حركهم ويهاجمون
مقر للبسيج بمدينه اراك والنظام يلجا
للمحكمات العالميه
واسطه اجراءات امنيه مشدده الناخبون
الاسرائيليون يبدون باصواتهم لاختيار
اعضاء الجسم
يطالبوا شركات النفط الامريكيه بزياده
الانتاج وخفض الاسعار ويتواعدها برفع
الضرائب
اهلا بكم نشير الى حضراتكم الان الى بعض
التصريحات الصادره عن الخارجيه الاوكرانيه
اوكرانيا تقول انه يجب استبعاد روسيا من
مجموعه العشرين نتيجه استهدافيها لاهداف
مدنيه اوكرانيه كان احاديث يدور في
الاوساط السياسيه عن امكانيه حضور بوتين
لاجتماع العشرين كانت هذه الانباء قد
تسربت بالفعل وسبقها ايضا تصريحات الليله
بروف يتحدث فيها عن امكانيه التحور ما بين
اوروبا وما بين بوتين اذا ما كانت هناك
شروط وصفها بالواقعيه هذه تطورات متلاحقها
وايضا مجلس دوما الروسي يشير ايضا الى انه
لا يمكن العوده الى اتفاق الحبوب بنفس
الشروط التي وضعت مسبقا روسيا اعلنت تعليق
المشاركه في هذا الاتفاق حتى اللحظه قالت
التصريحات انه ليس خروجا من المشاركه في
الاتفاق ولكنه اعلان او تعليق فقط
يتوافدوا قضت الدول العربيه على الجزائر
المشاركه في عمل القمه العربيه الحاديه
والثلاثين الموزمعي عقدها اليوم وعقد
مندوب الوفود العربيه امس اجتماعه لصياغه
بنود مشروع بيان القمه هذا وتعض قمه
الجزائر هي الاولى منذ ثلاثه سنوات او
ثلاث سنوات وتعقد تحت شعار لم الشمل
وعشيه القمه اكد الامين العام المساعد
للجماعه العربيه حسام زكي للعربيه ان قمه
الجزائر ستعيد تاكيد على رفض تدخلات تركيا
وايران وشدد زكي على ادانت تدخلات
الايرانيه كافه في المنطقه واعرب عن امله
في ان تتجاوب المغرب والجزائر مع جهود
الحوار
لا نريد
القمه في حد ذاتها تكون
يعني مسار للخلاف هي بالعكس هي المفروض
ونامل كنا جميعا انها تكون
[موسيقى]
هي دافع للالتقاء والحوار
نكون انه حصل بعض الامور
واستطعنا احتوائها في حنه بالفعل
لكن بالنهايه هذه قرارات دول وقرارات قاده
وهمم جلاله الملك اتخذ قراره همم معرفه
وثيقه بكل التطورات التي حدثت همم
يعني انا عاده لا افقد الامل ايه
والدبلوماسيه هكذا لا يجب ان تفقد الامل
ناصر بوريتها العربيه انه يتعاثر على
العاهل المغربي حضور القمه العربيه
الاعتبارات اقليميه برضا اعتبر ايضا ان
اضاحات الجزائر بشان ازمه الخريطه لم تكن
مقنعه وان القمه العربيه حدث الرئيسي
لكنها لا تختزل العمل العربي المشترك
واضاف ان التورتي الورد الاعلامي وصل
للجزائر وعدم من المطار لسبب غير واضح
امس اخبارنا الجامعه العربيه بانه يتعذر
على جلاله الملك حضور اشغال القمه كان
جلاله الملك محمد السادس من اول القضاء
عن استعدادهم لحضور هذا القمه
وكان جلاله الملك
حتى تعليمات
الدول العربيه عن استعداد جلاله الملك
للقيام بهذه السياره للحضور القمه وتشجيعز
يعني القضاء العرب على القيام بذلك
جلاله الملك
الاشغال ولكن جلاله الملك عنده اعتبارات
مرتبطه
سياق اقليمي ثنائي وغيره
ابدا وزير الخارجيه الجزائري رمطانا
عمامره تفاجؤه من عدم حضور العاهل المغربي
الملك محمد السادس القمه العربيه التي
تحتضنها الجزائر معربا عن عدم مشاركته او
ان عدم مشاركته ضيعت ربما فرصه للصلح بين
البلدين
همم
محمد السادس سيشارك شخصيا فيه هذه القمه
علما صباح اليوم ان الامر ليس ليس كذلك
فاعتقد انه
يبقى من صلاحيه المريخين ان يصدر حكمه
مستقبلا عن ما اذا كانت هناك فرصه ضاعت
للمغرب العربي للعمل العربي المشترك واذا
كان الجواب بالنهار انه فعلا ضاعت فرصه
همم من يتحمل فرصه ضياع ام المسؤوليه تلك
تلك الفرصه
ونذهب الى الملف الليبي وفي تطور جديد على
قائد الجيش الوطني خليفه حفتر عن اقتراب
اتخذه لما وصفه بالقرار الحسن لتحديد
المسار نحو استعاده الدوله تلفزيون
المصاري الليبيه النقل عن حفطر قوله ان
الجيش سيتحرك انسجاما مع اراده الشعب وذلك
بعد ان اوصلت المسارات السابقه البلاد الى
طريق مسدود ونتائج مخيبه على حد تعبيرهم
واضاف حفتر ان تجارب اثبتت ان اي حل شامل
او مبادره لن يكتب لها النجاح الا بمصادقه
الشعب الليبيه عليها اما بخصوص القوات
الاجنبيه في بلاده فاكد قائد الجيش الوطني
الليبي انه اذا فشلت المساعي السلميه في
اخراجها فان الجيش سيخوض معركه فاصله
لتحرير البلاد
ليبيا ايضا اغلقت مجموعه مسلحه من مدينه
الزاويه مدخل المدينه بسواتر ترابيه وقطعت
الطريقه الساحليه الرابط بين العاصمه
طرابلس والحدود التونسيه وافاد مراسل
العربيه بان المسلحين ارجعوا ذلك الاجراء
الى عدم صرف مستحقاتهم من قبل حكومه
الوحده الوطنيه المنتهيه ولاياتها
ويل تطورات في اليمن قتل طفلان و جرح
اربعه اخرون جرى سقوط قذفتيها هون
اطلقتهما الميليشيا الحوثيه غرب مدينه تعز
الحكومه اليمنيه طلبه المجتمع الدولي
باتخذه موقف واضح من جرائم القتل اليوميه
التي ترتكبها الحوثي بحق سكان مدينه تعز
المدرسه
بحق اطفال تعز في حي المطار القديمه غربي
المدينه
يعني تندري تحت جرائم الحرب ليس هناك اي
معارك ليس هناك اي مبررات المدنيين ساعات
فقط من مرور تلك الجريمه الحوثيه بحقها
هؤلاء لتتبعها جريمه اخرى
وعلى الحي نفسه
مع طفله ليوم الحزن ارجاء المنزل وترتفع
اعداد الضحايا بذلك الى قتيلين وخمسه جرحه
كلهم من الاطفال
واجي اشوف البيت كله مكسر واشوفه بقوم ميت
واشوف اي اخره ابن عمي
وابن عمي
رجله
مبخوتيه بحق الاطفال في المنزل هذا غربي
مغلش يتحمل
تعيش عشيره الاسر اليمنيه في الحج هذا
برعب دائم فمن نجا هنا من قناصه
الميليشيات قد لا ينجو مطلقا من مقذوفتها
التي تستهدفهم يوميا في منازلهم سعيد
العربيه تعز
الى القياسيه لخفض تكاليف الامريكيين
وزياده الانتاج او دفع معدل ضرائب اعلى
اعتقد ان عليهم مسؤوليات التصرف لصالح
المستهلكين ومجتمعهم وبلدهم للاستثمار في
امريكا من خلال زياده الطاقه الانتاجيه
والتكرير لا يريدون فعل ذلك لديهم الفرصه
للقيام بذلك تخفيض الاسعار للمستهلكين في
المضخه كما تعلم اذا لم يفعلوا ذلك فسوف
يدفعون ضريبه اعلى على ارباحهم الزائده
وسيواجهون قيودا اخرى سيعمل فريق مع
الكونجرس للنظر في هذه الخيارات المتاحه
لنا وللاخرين
ونبقى في الولايات المتحده حيث افادت
وزاره العدل بتوجيه تهمه الاعتداء على احد
افراد عائله مسؤوله ومحاولتي خطف مسؤول
وسطه ولقتحام الى الامريكي ديفيد ديفيد
وافادت دعوه الجنائيه اتحاديه ان المتهم
بضرب
زوجي بمطرقه هدد باخذها كراهينه وكسر
ركبتيها اذا كذبت عليه في استجوابه لها
وذكرت الدعوه ان المتسلله ابلغ بول بروسيه
بانه يعتزم احتجاز زوجته رهينه للاستجواب
وانه اذا قالت الحقيقه فسوف يتركها تذهب
رئيسه مجلس النواب الامريكي يناسب روسي
والتي كانت في واشنطن وقت الهجوم قالت ان
زوجها يتحسن تدريجيا لكنه سيحتاج لعمليه
تعاف طويله
لاول مره في تاريخ الانتخابات التشريعيه
الامريكيه تتخطى نسبه المشاركه في تسجيل
الناخبين 70 بالمئه وهذا يعكس بالطبع
حماسا غير مسبوق فقد تخطت نسبه حماسه
الجمهوريين للمشاركه في الانتخابات
65% اما الديمقراطيون فوصلت الى 62% لكن
كل معسكر بالطبع متماسك برايه واصطلاح
حاله استقطاب ملحوظه
[موسيقى]
توقيت
هذه هي هافان الصغيره
لمدينه مهاجرين تركوا بلدهم الام كوبا
واسسوا مجتمعا جديدا في قلب ميامي
يتحدث اللغه الانجليزيه
[موسيقى]
التخوف من ركود اقتصاديه متوقع الصرف
الحكوميه في اوكرانيا لا يروقوا للناخبونه
غير جيد بسبب الاموال التي تقدم الى
اوكرانيا من الحكومه اعطت الكثير من
الاموال لدول اجنبيه
في محل تجاري التقينا بابا كان اول من صنع
قميص المزارع الكوبي المعروف باسم كوبا
فيرا ويقر ان ليتل هافانا منطقه سياحيه
لكنه متخوف من ركود اقتصاديه وتضخم سيؤثر
على مدخوله لذا فهو متحمس للتصوير الشاشه
طويله وسنشعر باذيه الركود خلال الاسابيع
او الاشهر المقبله
حيث انه اذا فشلنا فهذا سيؤثر على الجميع
تماما مثل اثر لعبه الدومينو نعرف ان كل
الدول بما فيها الاوروبيه ستصاب بالركود
ما هو ملحوظ في هذه الانتخابات وان كل
معسكر متمسك بارائه فالناخب الذي يصوت
للجمهوريين يرى ان البلاد تسير في الاتجاه
الخاطئ والذي سيصوت للديمقراطيين يرى ان
البلاد محاصره والديمقراطيه في خطر وتبقى
حاله التشردم والانقسام طاغيه وسينعكس هذا
على صناديق الاقتراعه
[موسيقى]
العربيه ميامي
الله
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
يوتيوب
قال الملياردير لهم ماسك الذي سحوده على
شركه تويتر مقابل 44 مليار دولار ان
التزام منصه التواصل الاجتماعي بسلامه
العلامه التجاريه لم يتغير وكان تقارير
اعلاميه افادت بان ماسك قام بحل مجلس
اداره موقع تويتر واعلن بانه سيكون رئيسه
تنفيذيه للشركه وقم ماسكا في وقت سابق
بتغيير وصفه في سيرته الذاتيه على المنصه
الى رئيس تويتر في اشاره الى هذه الخطوه
ارتفع عدد القتلى انهيار جسر مشاه في
الهند الى 135 مع دخول عمليات الانقاذ
يومها الثالث وكان الجسر الذي يعود الى
الحقبه الاستعماريه فوق نهر ناتشو في
موربي بالزوار الذين يستمتعون باحتفالات
الاعياد عندما انهار في بدايه الاسبوع
ليسقط نحو 200 شخص في الماء
ختامن العناوين
بوتين يعتبروا الهجمات على البنا التحتيه
الاوكرانيه ردا على استهداف اسطول البحر
الاسود ويحذر ثياب من المزيد
محتجون ايرانيون يواصلون حركهم ويهاجمون
للبسيج بمدينه اراك والنظام يلجا
للمحاكمات العالميه
المشدده الناخبون الاسرائيليون باصواتهم
الاختيار اعضاء الكنيسه
بايديني يطالبوا شركات النفط الامريكيه
بزياده الانتاج وخط الاسعار ويتوعدها برفع
الضرائب
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]